jours à vous merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france donc le dépôt des
candidatures pour cette présidentielle a
débuté aujourd'hui à une candidature
certaine selon les médias iraniens c'est
celle du général de brigade mohammad
hassan nani nami qui est un membre de
l'armée régulière l'ancien ministre des
télécommunications est ce que une
présidence militaire est possible à
l'issue du prochain scrutin présidentiel
en iran
il peut être possible parce que les
élections présidentielles si on prend
même conditionné aux résultats qu'il y
aura avec lien reprise des négociations
sur le nucléaire iranien via lé depuis
début avril avec la date butoir en tout
cas pour les européens et la communauté
internationale qui 21 mai date qui en
fait signifiera la fin de l'accord
intermédiaire permettant aux inspecteurs
de la ive a de pouvoir mener leur
instruction sur des sites nucléaires
iraniens et donc les résultats des
négociations seront également la levée
des sanctions américaines vis-à-vis de
téhéran et à partir de là effectivement
ça déterminera beaucoup de l'issue des
élections présidentielles qui voit alors
se tiendront le 18 juin
alors avec le départ annoncé d'hassan
rohani qui ne peut pas briguer un
troisième mandat qu'elle relève possible
pour les réformateurs et modérés bien il
est possible que voilà les nourrir et
puissent avoir un accès président si
effectivement il ya une vague levée des
sanctions américaines et dossier dans le
cas avec 2 voilà des négociations de
reprise de négociations bon moment en
direct entre les états unis et puis
vivent sous la halle de l'union
européenne aviaire alors justement il ya
des ministres des affaires étrangères
mohammed javad tarifs qui étaient en
pleine tourmente 1 puisqu'il a été
affaiblie par cette affaire
on l'a vu dans le sujet précédent des
fuites d'un entretien dans lequel il a
critiqué le rôle de l'ex général qasem
soleimani tué dans une attaque
américaine en janvier 2020 à bagdad
l'influencent aussi la critique l
influence des gardiens de la révolution
dans la politique étrangère iranienne
est-ce qu'il peut être lui mis en
position de se présenter pour cette
présidentielle
il le peut mais force est pas du tout à
l'ordre du jour pour le moment
c'est peut-être est-ce que justement les
sa candidature elle peut être retenue
par le conseil des gardiens de la
constitution iranienne moment c'est que
les peler les candidatures avec des
profils un petit peu plus militaires
sont pendant vos revenus au car
justement il y aurait une extension d'un
quelconque accord sur le nucléaire
iranien qui voudrait que voilà sans
encadre également le programme de
missiles balistiques iraniens selon la
volonté américaine et le régime iranien
vous à s'assurer que justement s'il ya
une quelconque extension qui touche
justement la défense du régime général
puis voilà la partie militaire puisse
être aux commandes pour pouvoir négocier
l'extension est du côté des
conservateurs des ultraconservateurs
c'était bien de camp conservateur
quelles sont ses chances justement pour
en vue de cette présidentielle
elles sont élevés mais elles dépendront
également voile à l'issue des
négociations qui se rapproche
concernant la mort de vieillesse il ya
eu élection il ya des chances pour que
justement ça soit le parti nous verrez
qu'ils puissent passer et si
effectivement il ya un échec de l'autre
côté là le parti conservateur en un peu
plus de chance d'accéder à la présidence
évidemment vous l'avez bien précisé un
des enjeux de ce scrutin autour du
nucléaire iranien et mais le poids aussi
de la gâteau l'arménie
tout à fait maintenant mais n'y aura son
dernier mot à dire constitutionnellement
l'élection des candidats du candidat
final les scénarii possibles selon vous
à quel terme justement sur les saisies
scrutin ça dépendra à réellement
justement de l'évolution des pourparlers
sur le nucléaire iranien
oui c'est vrai que je pense des
négociations mais en l'état actuel des
choses
comment est ce que vous voyez vous les
scénarii possibles et bien que si voilà
il est levée des sanctions économiques
qui est satisfaisante pour l'iran le
congrès aura des chances de passer
si ça ne l'est pas ça sera plutôt le
plan conservateur mais tout en gardant
l'esprit que les américains sont donc de
retour à la télé négociations pour
pouvoir d'abord rétablir l'accord qui
encadrent le prendre un purement
nucléaire et avec la volonté de par la
suite pouvoir étendre cet encadrement au
programme de missiles balistiques
iraniens qui défendent normalement n'est
pas encadré participer au et est de ce
fait tant mieux mais que valent à la
république islamique d'iran prépare
également la suite de celui qui va
succéder justement au guide suprême
il faudrait que ça soit un membre du
camp conservateur a également un membre
de l'as réalité en ce sens très large
thèmes qu'ils puissent être autrement
pour pouvoir négocier ceni le français
sert l'association fille et c'est
encadrement de ce qu'ils touchent
vraiment la défense du régime iranien
merci beaucoup à vous astrid you docteur
en sciences politiques et sociales à
l'université de louvain